what's going on guys this is rob and i
don't have my hat on but it doesn't
matter because you guys don't care have
you guys seen all the news and rumors
and like everything that's dropped for
spider-man no way home for like the last
day and a half
it's crazy man it's absolutely crazy all
the stuff that's come out but here's the
thing some of the stuff that's come out
is actually kind of disappointing
because it just crushes hopes and dreams
that we had but to kind of get into this
one of the first things that we've seen
recently is actually from empire
magazine
when you get this amazing shot of doctor
octopus fighting tom holland right i
mean it's a it's this is not the world
of harry potter right so it's not this
is it's like a static image it's not
moving
although it'd be amazing if it was
if magazine covers were basically just
gifts that would be awesome
but the scene itself
looks great dude i gotta be honest with
you guys man i'm not even gonna lie here
i feel like i'm not the only one who's
really more excited for the fight
between dr octopus and tom holland
than like anything else right like
any number of things could happen iron
man could come back and i would probably
still be more excited for the fight
between doc ock
and tom hall and spider-man because it's
just like it's like the thing we've been
waiting for man
you know
like it's the thing we've wanted to see
for the longest time right you know but
but nonetheless it looks cool it looks
awesome but the empire magazine article
actually mentioned a couple other things
and one of the things that it does is it
seems to put the plot of spider-man 3
more into context and give us a much
better idea of what's going on here
because the reality is it's just been
nothing but fan theories and guessing
games since the trailer dropped and
before the trailer even dropped right
like at this point you could tell me
that some part of the plot of spider-man
3 involves the eternals enlisting the
aid of the mutants who have basically
been gone the entire time or have been
been hiding the entire time to fight the
sinister six and i would probably be
like i mean it's possible right at this
point like we don't know
we have no indication exactly what's
going to go on but this interview really
begins to put things into context one of
the things that it says here is that of
course as we expected you know just
based on what we saw with the trailer
that doctor strange was casting the
spell that was going to make the world
forget that peter parker was spider-man
peter parker couldn't shut the hell up
and the spell went awry we know that
much from the trailer what this article
also seems to go on to say is that the
nature of the spell was such that it
actually brought in a bunch of these
villains who know that peter parker is
spider-man and basically wanted to take
out spider-man this is kind of
interesting because precious few people
should know that peter parker is
spider-man so bringing in these villains
as a way to kind of tease the idea of
the sinister six looks cool if i'm being
honest with you guys that kind of seems
to be the brunt of the movie given this
interview or given the the article
itself and so on the image that we saw
the trailer kind of putting it all into
context what it looks like is the plot
seems like it might be a lot more simple
than we're initially led to believe i
think that once you start getting
towards the end that's when you're going
to start ramping up and getting into
stuff like things that lead into doctor
strange 2 and so on and so forth i
imagine the post credit scene for this
movie is going to just be stupidly
amazing but the thing about this is that
if all of this is to be believed right
that we're going to get electro and
we're going to get sandman and we're
going to get lizard we already know
we're going to get dr octopus we already
know that we're going to get uh the
green goblin and the rumors of paul
giamatti's rhino which nobody asked for
that that's gonna show up as well it
sets the stage for the sinister six and
the plot of the movie based on this
although in a second i'll actually tell
you guys about something that seems to
just kind of
damn all that right it just seems to
just eliminate all of that what it looks
like the plot would be is that all these
villains ended up in the marvel
cinematic universe because dr strange's
spell had something to do about bringing
them in and that what you actually end
up getting is andrew garfield and toby
mcguire and tom holland who team up to
face the sinister six now there's a
couple problems that i have with this
idea first and foremost the fact that if
the sinister six is going to get a movie
that it should be a movie that doesn't
feel like it's kind of crammed in there
right uh i do kind of like this idea but
the the significance of the sinister six
is that they almost defeated spider-man
more so than that spider-man defeated
the sinister six and the way the
original comic played out each member of
the of the villainous team faced off
against peter parker in a location that
was the most conducive to them so for
example when spider-man fought electro
he fought him in a power plant right
where elektra was at his absolute best
and spider-man still won so that kind of
a thing is what really elevated the
capabilities of spider-man and showed
you what he was really capable of when
you look at tom holland you still don't
get like a strong idea of what he's
really able to do because most of the
stuff that he's achieved has been with
the help of someone else in spider-man 1
you got a lot of scenes where he was
helped by iron man and spider-man 2 it
was him and mysterio and then he had to
face off against mysterio in the end but
you never saw a thing where it was like
something like the sinister six right
these villains that we are just over the
course of spider-man films aware of in
terms of what they can do all of whom
are teaming up to face off against one
spider-man and he still wins despite the
fact that it should be completely and
totally impossible i feel like that's
what the movie should be having said
that i think it's cool if we got toby
maguire and we got andrew garfield and i
think in all honesty if anything this
would set the stage for like some kind
of tie-in or involvement with the end of
the spider-verse films but that seems to
be the direction of the plot
at least until about 20 minutes ago
and then director john watts went on
twitter or did like an interview and
he's like no man the rumors of like
electro and and sandman and lizard
showing up it's just that right it's
rumors they're not going to be in the
movie now you can take that as you want
to because i interviewed john watts and
it was it was kind of a cringy interview
but i interviewed john watts and john
watts struck me as the kind of guy that
would be like no
those guys are not going to appear in
the marvel cinematic universe you're not
going to see them in the mcu there's no
way they would appear in spider-man 3.
not gonna happen
just be aware
not to expect it you and i mean like
that kind of guy
hint nudge nudge wink wink you know that
kind of a thing so again it may be one
of these things where he's actually
telling the truth and he's like no
they're not going to appear there which
if anything would actually kind of help
the whole like mystery and intrigue
there's a whole lot going on in this
film because from what we've seen in
terms of just like the early screenings
from people who have seen the things
that they've seen before they went back
and reshot a few things here and there
and so on and so forth the early
indications is that the movie has a lot
going on there's a ton going on which
actually kind of fits the colloquial
name for the film as it's being referred
to which is spider-man end game what
this means for the future of tom holland
i don't know it kind of goes either way
some people are saying that it means
that like once this movie's done tom
holland is finished in the mcu other
people are saying no it's basically a
reshuffling right it's like when mobile
comics comes along and they issue a new
number one for a character and they
change a few things up right and so
stuff's a little bit different than it
was before characters that you knew have
basically been removed or whatever the
case is then it's like a soft reboot for
the character of tom holland right uh i
have heard and i don't know how true
this is i have heard that aunt may dies
in the movie i don't know if that's true
i'm not gonna lie i kind of feel like
it'd be significant i don't feel like
that should happen here's the reason why
i feel like that should happen right and
i know it sounds terrible but here's the
reason why it would matter it would be
important right the one death that the
tom holland spider-man universe does not
have that it needs to have was the death
of gwyn stacey but gwen stacy doesn't
really seem to exist in the traditional
sense sorry so you guys don't know what
that means in the comics of course you
guys know uncle ben died the death of
uncle ben taught peter parker the
reality of the lesson he was trying to
teach him with great power must come
great responsibility a line that we're
supposedly supposed to hear in the movie
which would be amazing but that's but it
taught him that right peter parker had
the power to stop a criminal but he
didn't the result was that it led to his
uncle ben dying so with great power must
come great responsibility the death of
when stacy taught peter parker he can't
be reckless with what he does that he
can't let villains escape if he can stop
them that he can't just leave and then
come back another day but when it comes
to saving people not everyone has the
same capabilities he does when he shot
his webbing into the foot of gwen stacey
in the comics and depending on who you
talk to it snapped her neck and it
killed her although some people say that
when green goblin said she was already
dead the green goblin was right he
killed gwen stacy before she showed up
so basically peter parker broke the neck
of a dead girl regardless if he actually
did kill gwen stacy with his action he
was being reckless there and it taught
him he can't be that way right so both
of those deaths totally shaped peter
parker in the future of marvel comics
and that death doesn't exist right the
gwen stacy type death doesn't exist you
could point to the death of iron man but
really the death of iron man was kind of
the the continuation of this hero's
journey in the sense that iron man was
the mentor of spider-man and when he
died it was now basically peter parker
graduating out into the greater tribe
and becoming a superhero that has to
stand on his own two feet and what that
means when he can't really call for help
in the traditional sense which is to say
there isn't really anybody out there
like iron man that can help him or bail
him out so again it's one of those kind
of significant moments there for his
character but i like the idea that if
what john watts said is true that really
only doc ock and only uh agree goblin
are going to appear in this movie then
it lends credence to the idea that
bigger things are going to happen do i
think stuff like venom is going to
appear in the mcu and in the sense like
he and spider-man are going to team up
no i mean it'd be cool but again like
it's been said multiple times that's
something they want to do much later on
supposedly matt murdock's going to
appear but for one scene and a lot of us
kind of guessed that he was going to be
the guy that was going to get peter
parker off the murder wrap and he was
going to go forward and kind of do his
own thing right so suppose it'll be that
one scene which would be cool that kind
of cohesiveness that netflix the the
shows just never gave us
[Laughter]
despite the fact that they knew it's
what we wanted right whatever the case
is i'm excited to see that regardless
like all this news and stuff that's
coming out for spider-man is kind of
crazy but i think the announcement from
john watts that electro lizard and
sandman are not going to appear in the
movie i feel like it's kind of crushing
to a few people right it's going to kind
of destroy a few people's hopes in terms
of what the movie was going to look like
but let me know down in the comments
section what you guys think about all
this are you guys excited and let me
know just based off of your your just
desires and what you're hoping and
dreaming is in this movie what scene do
you want to see most in spider-man 3
whether it's in the trailer or in any
kind of magazine articles or not right
your dream scene from spider-man 3 the
one scene that you would want to see in
this movie that you just feel like would
just be amazing let me know down in the
comment section with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i'll
catch you all later
peace